here with reaction founder of the
committee to unleash Prosperity Steve
Moore and co-host of the bottom line
Sean Duffy I was just on the bottom line
of fox business with Sean earlier great
show and Stephen I get your newsletter
all the every day and it is the must
read of the perspectives the Insight
it's great but let's start with that
because Biden is doing his tour about
how great binomics has been they're
admitting that the inflation reduction
Act was a climate bill you know it was
the green New Deal is what it was and
what we saw was mortgages increasing
rent increasing food inflation that the
the St energy costs were good it's not
going to be Summer Forever we're heading
into winter the gas prices the the
Staples that allow people to live their
lives in a manner that they want to
freely have all been chopped off at the
knees tell me your perspective on
exactly what's happening
yeah so the the gas price is one of the
kind of best indication of how Americans
are feeling about the economy because we
all fill up our tank you know every week
or every couple of weeks and so just to
give an indication of how much worse
things are Tammy than when Trump was
President 239 a gallon when Trump left
president Tammy today 389 a gallon in
many states by the way it's four dollars
a gallon or more I just uh filled up
from Virginia paid 439 a gallon so
you're basically paying twenty dollars
more every time you fill up your gas
tank Gabby thanks to Biden's policies
let's not forget you you and Sean both
remember this the first policy that uh
Joe Biden put in place when he got into
the White House was to kill pipelines
this has been a war on American Energy
and it's one of the reasons we've seen
this High inflation and I just want to
make one other quick point if I may
Tammy because you made a really
important Point earlier on the show and
I want to Echo this people say Trump
can't win he can't win the polls are
showing he can't win if you ask people
do you approve of trump personally a lot
of people say no but Tammy if you ask
people do you like Donald Trump's
policies the way he handled the economy
the way he handled the border the way he
handled energy policy the way he
deregulated and cut taxes people say
overwhelmingly yes I like those policies
and that's why I think Trump is going to
Trump uh Biden when it comes to these
economic issues yeah and that's key I
think Sean is that we know again with
all of our polls the economy is number
one for obvious reasons nothing else
matters if you're if you're poor if you
have no money if you can't predict the
next week of what's going to be on the
table we know it's I think with
inflation it's about 700 more a month
for Americans to just live their lives
Sean do you see that the nature of what
Americans are facing with crime and
everything else that the economy is the
thing that matters so you've got a big
family you know what it costs to raise a
family
so two things happened one Steve
mentioned gas prices we do that every
other day or every third day but it's
also prices that we pay in the grocery
store that's up 20 by the way I think
that number is really low when I shop
for my nine kids I feel like it's up 50
so when we're spending money on a daily
basis we see prices that have gone up so
much and then you're like well what is
Joe Biden done you had the inflation
reduction act you had chips
infrastructure covet relief most
Americans haven't seen any benefit from
all of the money that Joe Biden has
spent over five trillion dollars and
they look at their own lives and they're
worse off so yeah yeah Tammy I think Joe
Biden is being blamed by the American
voter and if I was Joe Biden I would say
listen the economy is not going well for
me eighty percent of Americans think
that the economy is going in the wrong
direction why don't I blame covet why
don't I blame Donald Trump for the
economy he hasn't done that he's leaning
in and saying bionomics is working don't
believe Your Lying Eyes you're doing
great America and I'm and I'm to blame
this is is the most insane political
strategy that any consultant ever came
up with because it's not going to work
the American people aren't going to buy
it because they're paying every day with
dollars they don't have Joe Biden's
economy you know it's the madness and
just very briefly Steve we know that
Biden promised the victims of the Maui
fire 700 on this within the same week
200 million more dollars going to
Ukraine so we're people Americans are
wondering what is our priority
financially about where we do spend
large amounts of money
this is one of the biggest scandals I'm
so glad you're covering this Tammy The
Wall Street Journal reported yesterday
on the front page that the liberal
Democrats spent more money on a climate
change policy in Hawaii than forest fire
mitigation exactly the forest fires in
Hawaii and the people who died was not a
result of climate change it was a result
of climate change fanaticism that is
misspending our public dollars yeah this
is they were focused on the the new
energy the renewable energies and one
argument is is that the the electric
company then ignored their
infrastructure repairs that's why there
has to be an investigation to determine
if that is true They begged for the
money they were they were begging for
the money because they knew a forest
fire was you know quite a real
possibility and they did nothing because
they were concerned about you know how
are we going to do solar power and wind
power and things like that this is an
epidemic of craziness it is in in terms
of their environmental gentlemen and
clearly more investigations and the one
benefit off this
Tammy is that the media started off by
saying this is global warming and we
have to do all these radical additional
policies and now we are seeing to
Steve's point on your point that this
was actually a failure of government
where the power companies weren't
actually clearing out the underbrush
under their lines and they weren't using
water to put out fire that's right it
was a government policy problem not
climate change yeah in a way it was
climate fanaticism that caused this uh
because of the decisions that were made
all right so gentlemen thank you more to
come hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else